[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joining you today from the interval
in san francisco and our speaker today
roman kuznerick will be joining us live
from london where he'll also stay on to
do questions afterwards
roman is one of the research fellows
here at the long now foundation
and he's been writing about issues of
long-term thinking for many years
his newest book the good ancestor is
possibly one of the most long now
aligned books
since stuart brand wrote clock of the
long now today he's coalesced several of
the principles of that book into kind of
practical ways of thinking and doing
long-term thinking
and he's going to share several of those
with us today welcome
roman kuznerick a few years ago
i was sitting in a log cabin in the
austrian alps
reading a book that set my mind on
fire and this is the book
the salt summaries seminars on long-term
thinking
published by the long now foundation in
fact
this book was so good that i read it
twice and it contains
these incredibly pithy summaries of the
long now seminars going back
to the year 2003 with extraordinary
insights from thinkers ranging from
geologists
and astronomers to environmental
historians
and reading this book made me understand
that long-term thinking is of
extraordinary importance for the future
of human civilization
but while reading it i also recognize
something else
which is that in society at large
we are facing a conceptual emergency
of long-term thinking you can pick up a
newspaper and see all sorts of people
talking about the problem of
short-termism
and the need for long-term thinking
ranging from medical doctors and
politicians to
tech ceos and designers but there is
very little
clear discussion about what long-term
thinking really
means whether there are different kinds
of long-term
thinking whether it's always good for us
how to make it a social norm
whether you can get better at it and
that's exactly what i decided to explore
in my book
the good ancestor which tries to create
a
mental framework for thinking about
long-term thinking
and it comes out with these six
different ways
that we can think six different ways to
become
a good ancestor and i want to share some
of those with you today
but before doing that i want to just
pinpoint exactly why long-term thinking
matters it's clear that we live in an
age
of pathological short-termism our
politicians can barely see past the next
election
or even the latest tweet businesses
can't see past the next quarterly report
markets spike then crash in speculative
bubbles
nations sit around international
conference tables focused on their
near-term interests
while the planet burns and species
disappear
and as individuals we're constantly
answering the latest text and clicking
the buy now button
this is the age of the tyranny of the
now
and it's obvious i think that we need
long-term thinking to deal with this
tyranny of the now we need it to do
long-term planning in public health care
to get ready for the next pandemic that
might be on the horizon
we need it to tackle racial injustice
that gets passed on from generation
to generation embedded in criminal
justice systems and
cultural institutions more broadly we
need it to
prepare us for technological risks such
as the risks from ai controlled lethal
autonomous weapons
and of course we need long-term thinking
to help us confront
the challenge of the climate crisis
biodiversity loss
soil degradation our addiction to fossil
fuels
and there's a kind of paradox here which
is that the need for long-term thinking
is incredibly urgent we need it right
here
right now and the way i think about this
is that i believe that humankind
has colonized the future we treat the
future like a distant colonial outpost
where we can freely dump
ecological degradation and technological
risk
as if there was nobody there and it's a
bit like the way when britain colonized
australia in the 18th and 19th century
they drew on a legal doctrine
now known as terror nullius nobody's
land they treated the continent as if
there were no indigenous people
of course they were and i think today
what we've also got
alongside terenalis is tempus nullius
the future is seen as nobody's time
an uninhabited territory that is ours
for the taking
and the tragedy is that tomorrow's
generations aren't here to challenge
this pillaging of their inheritance
they can't leap in front of the king's
horse like a suffragette
or stay just sit in like a civil rights
activist or go an assault march to defy
their colonial oppressors
like mahatma gandhi the grant had no
political rights or representation
they have no influence at the
marketplace the great silent majority of
future generations
is rendered powerless but it can be very
difficult to grasp
the scale of this injustice so look at
it this way
there are 7.7 billion people alive today
now over the past 50 000 years an
estimated
100 billion people have been born and
died
but both of these are far outweighed by
the nearly 7
trillion people who will be born over
the next 50 000 years
assuming current birth rates stabilize
so there in that giant
orange circle are all your grandchildren
and their grandchildren and the friends
and communities on whom they'll depend
and i think the question that really
matters is how are those future
generations
going to judge us for what we did or
didn't do
when we had the chance and somebody who
really thought about this
problem was the immunologist jonah sulk
who together with his team in 1955
developed the first
polio vaccine later in life he said
there's one
question that really matters and it's
this are we being good
ancestors in other words how are we
going to be remembered by
future generations and sulk believed
that if we were going to tackle the
great problems of the century
such as the nuclear threat or our
destruction of the living world
then we would need to expand our time
horizons
and instead of thinking on a scale of
seconds minutes and
hours we need to think on a scale of
decades
centuries and millennia and in many ways
i have good news which is that a global
movement of
time rebels has started to emerge
absolutely committed to
this kind of long-term thinking and
intergenerational
justice and we see their work in lots of
different
areas in the scientific world for
example there's the svalbard
global seed vault which is collecting
millions of seeds in an indestructible
rock bunker in the arctic circle
that's designed to last a thousand years
and preserve the planet's plant
biodiversity or
are iconic project projects like the
long now foundation's 10 000 year clock
which is a slow time clock being built
as we speak in the texas desert
which is going to stay accurate for 10
000 years and become almost a secular
altarpiece for a long-term thinking
civilization
helping us take responsibility for the
generations to come
and for the planet itself but there's a
question here really which is
how do we actually get better at
long-term thinking
and are we even actually capable of it
well i believe that in order to become a
better ancestor and long-term thinker we
need to
begin on a journey which starts in the
human mind
in fact in the human brain we know that
there is a constant struggle going on in
our minds between
the drivers of short-termism and
long-termism
we experience it all the time do we
party today or save for our pensions for
tomorrow
do we upgrade to the latest iphone or
plant a seed in the ground
for posterity and in fact these two
different
sides of short-term and long-term
thinking
brain and dilemma is actually mirrored
in two different parts of the brain
itself the short term part of the brain
is this
i call it the marshmallow brain it's our
neural wiring that we share with rats
going back nearly 80 million years
and this is the part of our brain that
focuses on instant rewards
and short-term gratification but the
marshmallow brain
of course is named after the famous
marshmallow test
a psychology text from the 1960s where a
marshmallow was placed
in front of children and if they could
resist eating it for 15 minutes
then they were rewarded with a second
marshmallow and of course it turned out
the majority of kids couldn't resist and
snatched the snack
and gobbled it up but the marshmallow
brain is only part of the story of who
we are
because we have another part of our
brains and here it is
it's the acorn brain the acorn brain is
the part that focuses on
long-term thinking and planning and
strategizing
it's about planting seeds in the ground
projects and ideals and policies that
may not come to fruition and mature for
years or even
decades and we've all got one it lives
here
in the frontal lobe above the eyes
particularly in a park called the
dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex it's a new part of the
brain
it's only a couple of million years old
but it's better developed in humans than
most other animals
so a chimpanzee for example plans for
the future
they might get a stick off a tree and
strip off the leaves to turn it into a
tool to poke into a termite hole
but they will never make a dozen of
these tools and set them aside for next
week
but that is precisely what a human being
will do
we are long-term planners extraordinaire
we plan for our children's educations
and save for them
we make plans of song lists for our own
funerals
it's the acorn brain in action it's the
acorn brain which helped us build the
great wall of
china and voyaged into space so what we
need to do
is learn to switch on our acorn brains
so we can win this
struggle going on with a marshmallow
brain
that's the beginning of becoming a
long-term thinker to recognize
that by nature we have this acorn brain
built into us the question it really is
how are we going to switch it on
and i think to do that we need to
recognize that in society at large
there is what i think of as a tug of war
for time going on between six drivers of
short-termism
and six ways to think long-term the six
drivers of short-termism
are dragging us over the edge of
civilizational
breakdown the six ways to think
long-term
are taking us towards a long-term future
for people
and planet and we need to draw on
the six ways to think long this
cognitive toolkit for long-term thinking
that i mentioned before
in order to really switch on our acorn
brain and become better ancestors
now if you look at the six drivers of
short-termism some of them are quite
familiar like digital distraction or
political presentism
you know the short-term electoral cycles
some of them are deeper such as the
tyranny
of the clock because the invention of
the clock in the medieval period
is a key moment in shortening our time
horizons
time started being measured and sped up
it's been going on for 500 years by 1700
most clocks had minute hands by 1800
they had second hands and the clock
became the key
instrument of the industrial revolution
keeping those assembly lines moving
faster and faster today of course we've
got nanosecond speed
share trading going on which has brought
the future closer and closer to the
present
but each of those drivers of six short
termism is matched by
a form of long-term thinking and now
what i'd love to do is
talk about each of these different ways
to think long-term because i think we
need
all of them we need to cultivate all of
them to
become better ancestors so the first
kind
is the idea of deep time humility
this is to recognize that humankind that
has only been around for a couple of
hundred thousand years
is just an eye blink in the cosmic
story in fact deep time is quite a new
idea
it only really emerged in the late 18th
century when geologists started
discovering the evidence that the earth
was far older than the 6 000 years that
the bible was
telling western culture but was in fact
hundreds of thousands millions maybe
billions of years
old and that we were just a tiny moment
in this long
history of the planet and the universe
itself
but it can be quite difficult to really
grasp that
huge temporal scale and the writer john
mcphee who invented the term deep time
came up with a beautiful metaphor to try
and help us grasp
its meaning he said consider the earth's
history
as the old measure of the english yard
the distance from the king's nose
to the tip of his outstretched hand one
stroke of a nail file
on his middle finger
erases human history
that's short we've only been around for
that very eye blink
but let's remember too that deep time
doesn't just go
far into the past it goes long into the
future
in six billion years any creatures that
will be around to see
al sun die will be as different from us
as we are from the first
single celled bacteria
so this is what this humility of deep
time is all about
recognizing there's so much time before
us so much time to come
and who are we to break the great chain
of life
without ecological destruction and
dangerous technologies what kind
of arrogance is that that's what i get
out of deep time
and it helps me think to myself okay let
me try and get in touch with that
longer sense of time that ecological
choreography of the planet the long
cycles that we've lost touch with i'm
not saying this is easy
but we can make the effort you know i
was recently
on summer vacation with my children and
we went to a beach on the south coast of
england
and in our hands we held
belamites a fossil squid-like creature
that was 195 million years
old no human being had ever set its eyes
on this fossil that we'd hunted hours to
find
but that gave us a sense of the wonder
of deep time
or you can go and visit your local
ancient tree
probably within some miles or a short
bicycle ride from where you live
you there might be a tree that's over a
thousand years old maybe it's a
californian bristlecone pine which is
four thousand years old
not far from me there's a yew tree which
is maybe 1200 years old
and you can sit underneath it and follow
the advice of the vietnamese
monk titna han who said don't just do
something
sit there in other words don't take a
selfie of yourself but
try and absorb that sense of deep time
now a second form of long-term thinking
is what's known as
cathedral thinking this is the idea of
embarking on projects with
very long time horizons decades and
centuries ahead even beyond
the scale of our own lifetimes
themselves
and of course the idea of cathedral
thinking relates to
medieval cathedral builders who started
building their religious edifices
knowing they'd never necessarily be
finished within their own lifetimes
and many people say well these are just
you know rare occasions of medieval
european cathedral humans don't really
have this capacity for long-term
thinking
well in fact if you look over the last 5
000 years of human history
there is ample evidence of our capacity
to embark on these cathedral thinking
projects
there you can see 45 different
kinds of cathedral thinking that i've
gathered that appear in my book the good
ancestor
religious buildings infrastructure urban
design
scientific endeavors and i'd like to say
something about just a few of them
you can see there an image of alm
minster
a lutheran church in southwest germany
this is a classic example of cathedral
thinking
in 1377 the good citizens of alm decided
they wanted to have their own church
they'd finance it themselves
and well it wasn't finished for more
than 500 years until 1890 probably the
world's
longest crowdfunding project but they
embarked on it anyway
knowing they'd never see it finished
within their time
social movements too are engaged in
cathedral thinking the first suffragette
organization emerged in manchester
in 1867 they didn't achieve their aims
of votes for women for more than
half a century and that's typically the
case with major social movements
in issues like civil rights or
indigenous rights these struggles go on
for decades
and many of them are still ongoing but
this is all a kind of cathedral thinking
in the realm of social change
and then you can also see there a
photograph from victorian
london these are the great sewers of
london which were built
following the great stink of 1858 in the
decades leading up to then
raw sewage was being dumped in the
thames river
tens of thousands of people would die
each year from diseases such as cholera
but in the hot summer of 1858 the stench
from the thames was so bad
that it even wafted into the houses of
parliament right on its bank
and members of parliament couldn't stand
it in fact they had to put masks over
their faces
and this finally prompted them to
pass the legislation to build london's
first public sewage
system it was masterminded by sir joseph
baseljet
the chief engineer he worked with 22 000
workers
318 million bricks and over 19 years
they built a sewer system twice as big
as it needed to be at the time
and that's why it is still in use today
that was exemplary cathedral thinking
now these kinds of examples are
incredibly inspiring
but cathedral thinking is not always
good for us it can be directed to
very narrow and self-serving ends and
can can be incredibly destructive
just think that hitler wanted to have a
thousand-year reich that was a kind of
cathedral thinking
the political regime in north korea
wants to pass on power from generation
to generation
preserving its privileges through the
ages that's cathedral thinking
just think how much concrete has been
poured by humankind
if you put together all the concrete
that has been poured by our species
it would create a spherical coffin
covering the whole earth even all of the
oceans
two millimeters thick and we know that
concrete
is responsible for about eight percent
of the world's carbon emissions
and then think of cathedral thinking in
the corporate world too
a former head of goldman sachs gus levy
once said we're greedy
but long-term greedy not short-term
greedy
well i'm not an advocate of that kind of
cathedral thinking and that's why we
need to
join the long horizons of cathedral
thinking
with something else which is a third
approach to being a good ancestor which
is the idea
of intergenerational justice which is
caring about the welfare
and the interests of the generations to
come
now groucho marx allegedly said why
should i care about future generations
what have they ever done for me and i
think a lot of us intuitively feel that
i've got a lot enough problems in my
life
right here right now to start thinking
about those future generations decades
even centuries ahead
why should i do that well i think if you
think back to that big
orange circle all those billions upon
billions of people
will be born even in the next couple of
centuries alone we have a moral
obligation towards them because our
actions
affect their lives probably more than at
any moment
in history so we can have that thought
with our minds
but i think we can also develop an
impetus for
intergenerational justice by drawing on
indigenous cultures
for example the native american idea
of seventh generation decision making
practiced in many communities iroquois
communities
lakota communities a well-known chief in
the iroquois confederacy chief orrin
lyons once said
we are looking ahead as is one of the
first mandates given
us as chiefs to make sure every decision
that we make relates to the welfare and
well-being
of the seventh generation to come and
that is the basis by which we make
decisions in council
will this be to the benefit of the
seventh generation
and this kind of idea which is a form of
ecological stewardship
is expressed around the world in the
malaccus islands in indonesia
village councils also do seventh
generation decision making
or in aotearoa in new zealand maori
communities
have a different concept which is called
baka papa
which is their idea of lineage the idea
that we're part of a great chain of life
stretching long into the past
and far into the future and the light
happens to be shining here and now and
we need to
shine it more broadly when we're making
our decisions
and thinking about our impacts on the
generations to come
but what really excites me is that ideas
such as seventh generation thinking
which might seem very distant from
modern urban
life are actually finding their place
in radical change around
intergenerational
justice in japan for example there is an
extraordinary movement
called future design and it is directly
inspired by the native american
ideal of seventh generation decision
making what happens in future design is
that
local residents are invited to draw up
and discuss
plans for the towns and cities where
they live
but they're divided into two groups half
of them are told that they're residents
from the present day
the other half are given these almost
ceremonial robes to wear and told to
imagine themselves as residents from the
year 2060.
well it turns out the residents from
2060
systematically advocate far more
transformative city plans from
healthcare investment to climate change
action and this future design
movement is spreading from small towns
like yaha to major cities like kyoto
and the method is even being used in
japan's ministry of finance
so i would like to see future design
spreading to towns and progressive
cities and communities
worldwide to revitalize democratic
decision-making
and extend their vision far beyond the
now
but the idea of intergenerational
justice is also finding its place
in legal struggles in the u.s there is
an extraordinary organization called our
children's
trust a public interest law firm which
has filed a landmark
case on behalf of 21 young people
campaigning for the legal right
to a safe climate and healthy atmosphere
for both current
and future generations this is an
enormous shift in the history of human
rights one of the most important since
the french revolution
rights for future people now they are
engaged in a david vs goliath struggle
at both the federal and state level
but have already inspired landmark legal
cases worldwide from colombia
and uganda to the netherlands as well
and their actions exist alongside the
movement to grant legal personhood
to nature so for example in aotearoa in
new zealand the wanganui river sacred to
local maori people has been given legal
personhood
just like corporations have had legal
personhood since the late 19th century
so i think it's really important that we
get behind these movements
for intergenerational justice in the
legal sphere
in the political sphere in wales they
have a future generations commissioner
well why don't more countries have
future generations commissioners
this is part of the journey to a long
now civilization
now a fourth approach to long-term
thinking is what i think of as
developing
a legacy mindset just like
intergenerational justice a legacy
mindset
helps give direction to our long-term
thinking
and cathedral thinking now the idea of a
legacy is very important because we are
the inheritors
of legacies too inheritors of
extraordinary
positive legacies from the past the gift
of the agricultural revolution or
medical discoveries we still benefit
from
or the cities we still live in but we
are also the inheritors
of destructive legacies legacies of
slavery
and colonialism and racism creating deep
inequities that must now be repaired
legacies of economies that are
structurally addicted
to endless growth and fossil fuels that
must now be transformed
so we need to think very hard about what
kind of legacies we want to leave for
future generations
and the good news is that human beings
die
now why is that good news well basically
by the time we
reach midlife we start thinking about
how we're going to be remembered
when we are gone our mortality makes us
jump
our minds into the distant future but
the thing is we tend to express our
legacies in very different ways
some people want to leave a
egocentric form of legacy so they're
remembered for their
great glorious deeds for example a
russian oligarch might want to have a
football stadium or an art gallery wing
named after them a second kind of legacy
motivation is familial
legacy that's where we want to pass on
something to our own children but that
is
in itself is also a fairly narrow form
of legacy within our own
bloodline or our own personal
relationships
i believe a third kind of legacy is
required to be a good ancestor and
that's a
universal kind of legacy where we care
about the universal strangers of the
future we care about
the welfare of people we will never meet
now it can be quite difficult
to do that particularly in our
self-obsessed egotistical
hyper-individualistic consumer culture
how do we start connecting with those
generations two
three seven generations ahead well to do
that i think we need to go on a little
bit of an imaginative journey
and i'd like to take you through a short
thought experiment
uh which was developed by a long-term
thinker called ella saltmarsh
and the long time project so just
close your eyes for a moment and imagine
a child in your life who you really
care about it could be a nephew or niece
or one of your own children or
grandchildren
just picture their face
and now with your eyes still closed
imagine them
30 years in the future again picture
their face
think about the joys they might
experience
or the challenges they might be facing
now still with your eyes closed
imagine them on their 90th birthday
party
and they're surrounded by family and
friends and loved ones and old work
colleagues
go and have a look out the window what
kind of world is it out there
and now come back and look at their old
and wrinkled face
and then you see someone come over and
put a tiny baby into their arms
it's their first great grandchild and
they look into that baby's eyes and ask
themselves
what will this child need to survive and
thrive
for the years and decades ahead
just hold that thought for a moment
and now open your eyes again
and just think that tiny baby could be
alive well into the 22nd century
their future isn't science fiction it's
an intimate
family fact and certainly when i do that
thought experiment i think about my 11
year old daughter
as a 90 year old and i think about her
great grandchild i recognize that my
daughter
and that great grandchild are not alone
in the world they are part of a web of
relationships a web of people
a web of community and a web of the
living world the air that they breathe
the water they drink so if i care about
their legacy if i care about
their future welfare i have to care not
just about their life i have to care
about
all life in other words this kind of
thought experiment
is a bridge from a relatively narrow
form of familial legacy to a much more
broad universal sense of legacy of
caring about those
universal strangers of the future and
there's some wonderful
projects which try to tap into this kind
of legacy
thinking so for example the scottish
artist katie patterson
has started something called future
library a 100 year art project where
every year
for a century a famous writer is
donating a book
which will remain completely secret and
unread in the future library
until the year 2114 when the 100 books
will be printed on paper made from a
thousand trees that have been planted
in a forest outside oslo the first
person to donate a book was marca atwood
elif shafak and many other famous
writers have donated since but just
think margaret atwood is never going to
see that book
printed in her lifetime she's never
going to meet the readers this is a
legacy gift
to the future or another kind of legacy
project
is the green belt movement started in
1977
by the african activist wangari matai
who was the first african woman to win
the nobel peace prize
her ambition back in the late 70s was to
create a movement which
replanted trees all over kenya restoring
the natural world but also
taught agroforestry skills to women an
empowering women
project by the time she died in 2011
tens of thousands of women have been
trained up in agroforestry skills
more than 40 million trees have been
planted and the green belt movement is
still growing strong
working with women in over 4 000
communities across africa
what an extraordinary legacy gift and we
can all ask ourselves what kind of
legacies do we want to leave
to the generations of the future
now a fifth kind of long-term thinking
is what i call holistic forecasting
now forecasting goes back to ancient
egyptian priests who would try to
predict the size of the nile flood would
it be too big
too small or just right but then
forecasting became very much
a cold war affair after the second world
war
when it really started booming with
topics such as
scenario planning and then it became
adopted by the corporate world
but corporate forecasting these days
tends to be in the realm of three
five maybe ten years ahead but when i'm
talking about holistic forecasting i'm
talking about
centuries ahead or at least decades
ahead and thinking about not just the
fate
of a company or even a single country
but
the long-term forecast for human
civilization
itself this is long-term thinking that
it's very important
that we do because we must recognize an
important truth which is that
no civilization lasts forever the
cambridge university researcher luke
kemp did
a really important study of ancient
civilizations nearly 90 of them to find
out the average age
of an ancient civilization how long did
they last for well he discovered that
the average age for
one of these civilizations whether it
was the roman empire or
or carthage the average age was 336
years not very long and his point of
course was that
no matter how technologically advanced
or militarily strong
a civilization is it's not going to last
forever all civilizations
are born they flower and then they die
and so too it is with our own
civilization
ours will not last forever let us not
fall into that kind of
mythological trap we have to get ready
for our own demise and work out how are
we going to slow down
our civilizational decline as jared
diamond and many others have
identified in all their work or is it
possible to
jump onto a transformative pathway a new
civilizational pathway
and this takes me to my final form of
long-term thinking
the idea of pursuing a transcendent
goal now the great astronomer carl sagan
famously said that just as every
individual
needs a sacred goal to guide their
life to give it meaning and purpose so
too
does every civilization and our species
in itself the human species needs he
said
a telos which is the greek word for a
goal
or objective a load star to guide it
that can guide
in my view all the other forms of
long-term thinking
but what should that goal be for our
species what should we be ultimately
aspiring to
well i think if you look broadly at
public culture
there are three different goals that
have been identified as worthy
of our long-term future one of them i
call
perpetual progress this is the idea of
pursuing material improvement
and endless economic growth this has
been the de facto goal particularly of
western countries
since at least the end of the second
world war possibly since the
enlightenment
i mean in the last 70 years most
governments have prioritized the pursuit
of constant gdp growth whether they have
been
keynesian or marxist or neoliberal but
we now know that even though the pursuit
of material progress
and economic growth has brought us
enormous benefits over the past couple
of hundred years
particularly since the industrial
revolution it has come at a cost that is
no longer
supportable that cost is what's known as
the great acceleration
all those upswinging curves of carbon
dioxide emissions
ocean acidification deforestation which
has pushed us
over planetary boundaries into an
unstable earth system
shifting us from the period called the
holocene
where temperatures were stable and
agricultural civilization developed
into the new geological period of the
anthropocene
you know when my kids were little they
learned the problem of progress
that you can't keep blowing up a balloon
forever because at some point
it's going to pop so let's not think
that we can keep growing at two percent
or three percent or whatever we want
year upon year nothing in nature grows
forever
whether it's an oak forest or your
children's feet everything
follows an s-curve and eventually levels
off and dies off so
i think the idea of perpetual progress
is
a mythology we need to challenge and
together
with its ideas such as green growth or
sustainable growth
there is no evidence that we can
decarbonize and dematerialize growing
economies
at anything like the pace and scale
required to bring
us within safe planetary boundaries
particularly co2 emissions
fast enough you know that is just a myth
so we need to look at something else
well a second possible goal for
humankind a transcendent goal is the
idea of what i think of as techno
liberation
the idea that technology can solve our
problems and the prime contender here
is the idea that we can escape to other
worlds in fact if we're going to survive
as a species for the long term as carl
sagan
really said we needed to people other
worlds that's the only way to spread the
risk in case we destroy
this planet and the ultimate aim at
least for the moment is
let's get to mars let's colonize mars
now i'm here a follower of
people like the cosmologist martin reese
who believes that
colonizing mars should not be the
ultimate aim
of the human species it's partly because
it's so difficult
30 million miles away temperatures minus
100 degrees
nowhere as clement on mars as
the bottom of antarctica or the top of
everest and
even if we could maybe terraform mars
and there's no definite evidence that we
can do it it might take
hundreds maybe thousands of years it's
not an
solution to our urgent problems that we
face but the other problem as martin
reese pointed out is that the more we
focus on
colonizing mars and other planets as our
ultimate species aim the less we're
going to look after planet earth that
collateral damage
will be too high we need to look after
base camp earth as any mountaineer knows
you don't climb a risky peak until you
make sure your base camp
is in order and at the moment we haven't
learned to live within the boundaries of
base camp
earth so i don't think now is yet the
time to start
putting all our sights on going to mars
or
discovering other planetary homes and
that's why i believe the
third and primary goal for humankind
should be what i think of as one
planet thriving that's the idea of
meeting the needs of all current and
future people within the means of a
flourishing
planet this is the basic idea of
ecological economics
which has been around since hermann
daly's writings of the 1970s at least
and that's the idea that you know don't
use resources faster than they can be
naturally regenerated
and don't create wastes faster they can
be naturally absorbed by oceans and
other carbon sinks
it's not about endless growth it's about
thriving
in balance that is
really i believe the only way we should
be thinking when it comes to
our priorities for our species as a
whole
to live within the means of one planet
and someone who expressed this
absolutely beautifully was the
biomimicry designer and thinker janine
benyas
let me read you something that she said
she wrote the answers we seek the
secrets to a sustainable world are
literally all around us
if we choose to truly mimic life's
genius the future i see would be beauty
and abundance and certainly fewer
regrets
in the natural world the definition of
success is the continuity of life
you keep yourself alive and you keep
your offspring alive that's success
but it's not the offspring in this
generation success is keeping your
offspring alive for
10 000 generations or more that presents
a conundrum because you're not going to
be there to take care of your offspring
10 000 generations from now
so what organisms have learned to do is
to take care of the place
that's going to take care of the
offspring life has learned to create
conditions conducive to life
that's really the magic heart of it and
that's also the design brief for us
right now we have to learn how to do
that
now those words of janine bennies i
think are perhaps the most profound
words i've ever seen
about long-term thinking because they
tell us
the secret of long-term thinking in a
way which is that it's not just about
time it's about place
it's about caring for the place that
will take care of our offspring the one
and only planet we know that sustains
life
planet earth that is living within the
ecological boundaries
of the place in which we are embedded
it's about not fouling the nest which of
course is what humans have been doing
with devastating effects at an ever
increasing pace and scale
over the last century but how how do we
take this idea of
one planet thriving and put it into
practice well for that
i believe we need new economic models we
need to shift
into a post-growth mindset get off our
addiction to endless growth
and i think one of the most important
models that we could start thinking
about
is what's known as the doughnut the
donut of social and planetary boundaries
developed by the british economist kate
rayworth
and the way the donut works is this
there's two rings
there is a social foundation things like
water food basic health care
and the aim we should be prioritizing is
bringing people above that basic
social foundation but we need to do it
without pushing out
ourselves beyond the ecological ceiling
that's the outer ring of the donut
and the ecological ceiling is made up of
the nine planetary boundaries they're
called
which have been developed by earth
system scientists like johann rockstrom
and will stefan
things like climate change and ocean
acidification
caring for our soils chemical pollution
so
this model is not about growing growing
growing it's about
thriving in balance it's about getting
into the safe and just space for
humanity that
sweet spot that light green area there
this is what i believe the goal for
governments
today should be to ensure our long-term
future but
can we actually live within the doughnut
well let's have a look at where we are
today
on a global level this is our selfie and
what a devastating one it is
there's a shortfall on all of the social
foundations on a global level people
not able to meet their basic food or
health and other requirements that's
what those little red segments are
and when it comes to the ecological
sealing we're going over
at least four planetary boundaries the
ones for which we have good data
already and this donut model has also
been scaled down
from the global level to the national
level it's being used in cities such as
amsterdam it's being used by progressive
companies
so i believe that this is the kind of
economic thinking we
absolutely need for a long-term future
so there are six different ways to think
long-term six different
forms of approach to being a good
ancestor ways of switching on our acorn
brain
but there's a lingering issue here
because a lot of people say to me they
say
you know what's all this long-term
thinking all about you know it's so
difficult and governments are so
hopeless why don't we just have benign
dictators come along and sort it all out
for us
what we really need many people say are
enlightened despots and there is a
growing movement
of people believing this on both the
left and right the green
and the non-green well that's an
interesting idea to think about isn't it
is it actually true that authoritarian
governments are better
at delivering on long-term public policy
goals
and one might intuitively think yes or
just look at china aren't they great at
long-term
green infrastructure investment or look
at singapore
aren't they fantastic at their long-term
investment in housing and public health
care
so i thought about this and thought well
let's look at the evidence and in my
book the good ancestor
i actually look empirically at whether
dictatorships perform better than
democracies when it comes to long-term
thinking
and the way it's done in the book is
that i draw on a new index of
intergenerational solidarity
developed by a statistician called jamie
mcquilkin this is i think the best
long-term index in the world and it has
ten different indicators from three
different
areas which are put together so there
are environmental
indicators such as the amount of
renewable energy in the system
there are indicators of social matters
such as
uh investment in health care and then
there are there are economic indicators
such as inequality
they're put together into a single
number and then 122 countries are ranked
and in the rankings you can see that the
top performing countries in the world
are places like iceland and sweden but
also many non-wealthy countries such as
nepal or sri lanka and of course you
can't see china there china's down at
number 25 the uk is 45 the united states
is number 62.
there's a lot of variability in terms of
long-term policy performance
but then there's the question of what
how do these perform when it comes to
democracy and dictatorship we'll have a
look at this
this scatter plot shows the
intergenerational solidarity index on
the bottom axis
and on the y-axis going upwards is a
measure of democracy
called the v dem liberal democracy
measure and what you see there
is that the little dots of countries
clustering the top right and the bottom
left
that means the more democratic you are
the more
long-term your public policy is going to
be and the
less democratic you are the less
long-term your public policy is going to
be in fact of the top 25 countries on
the intergenerational solidarity index
21 of them are democracies of the 25
bottom scoring countries
on the inter-generational solidarity
index 21 of them
were autocracies and i think this really
puts an end
in a way to that benign dictatorship
argument there is no systematic
empirical evidence
that autocracies outperform democracies
when it comes to long-term public policy
in fact
quite the opposite and this is not
saying that democracies can rest easy
they all need to deepen
their democracy and inject more
long-term thinking into their
decision-making
but certainly the idea that the
dictatorship is going to solve all our
problems
is something that we have to i think
leave to the dustbin
of history so i really want to end by
recognizing that we
are at a moment of global crisis there's
the crisis of the pandemic
there's the ecological crisis and no
doubt there are financial crises
coming our way to in the months and
maybe years ahead
and historically i think we have to
recognize too that
crises are moments for change and
opportunity milton friedman the
economist famously said only a crisis
real or perceived produces real change i
think that's a pretty good historical
rule of thumb go back to the end of the
second world war out of the crisis of
the war
emerged extraordinary long-term
institutions the world health
organization the national health service
in britain
the european union and i believe that
here we are
at this moment of crisis in the early
21st century
and we have the opportunity to become
long-term thinkers
to draw on those six different ways
to switch on our acorn brains and i
believe that if we
rise to this challenge we truly can
become the good ancestors that future
generations
deserve thank you very much
thank you so much roman um that was
fantastic
welcome it's good to see you uh yeah and
i just wanted to say um
actually the good ancestor which was
supposed to be originally was going to
be out right before this talk aired
but uh is going to be out on november
3rd here in the united states um
holding the uk version now um so
november 3rd is election day and
you touched on politics there at the end
and it might be a good place for us to
start so anyway thank you
and welcome to us from london um
by the way we're doing this talk earlier
than we would normally do it because uh
we have uh roman here live from eight
hours ahead
in time so welcome thank you very much
for doing that by the way thank you
yeah you don't have to do the 2 a.m
version of your of your talk
uh well i wanted to start a little bit
with the politics i mean i think
um you know you touched on some of the
kind of bad forms of of long-term
thinking and i think we've
uh we've seen some of that in in
politics here in the united states with
things like the way
uh redistricting has been the slow burn
of kind of
changing uh uh congressional districts
to
uh not to be necessarily fair but to be
uh more tilted in in one way or another
and and
the politics is just an area that is
kind of rife with this
um and i wonder if you could say a
little bit more about that
yeah i think that when it comes to
long-term thinking
there hasn't been enough emphasis put on
how we can
in a way inject long-termism into the
dna
of democracy itself i think one
particularly finds this in the
environmental movement you know broadly
a sort of an unwillingness
to um really think about how we shift
political institutions partly because
it is so difficult to do that and so
that's why my book i focus quite a lot
actually on
the politics i partly do that also
because i used to be
a political scientist and i was
apparently an expert in democracy about
two decades ago and to my
shame during that time it never once
occurred to me
that we disenfranchise future
generations in the same way that in some
ways that you know women and slaves have
been disenfranchised
throughout history and that's still
ongoing of course of course there are
differences there but
those future generations are not part of
the political
conversation and you know there are
politicians of course who have always
been trying to manipulate the systems
for their short-term
gains gerrymandering of various kinds it
still tends to have quite
short-term uh ambitions it's about
winning the next election but
sometimes it's about trying to embed uh
that manipulation
in there but where i really have faith
where i'm
excited i think is um to look at the
citizen assembly
movement rising around the world in
countries like
ireland in spain belgium iceland canada
and other places
there's been a kind of revival of
participatory democracy i think in a way
as a counter
to the rise of far-right populism
and the sense that our major parties are
failing us when it comes to dealing with
climate change or dealing with
immigration issues or whatever it
happens to be so that's why i love that
example from japan where people are
wearing those
lovely robes because that's a kind of
grassroots revival of
the ancient greek idea of participatory
democracy and i'd like to see a lot more
of that i'd like to see britain's house
of lords
replaced by a house of the future
made up of everyday citizens right now
um
chile i i understand is undergoing a
process of
reconfiguring their constitution i'd
like to see it full of this kind of
citizen
assembly movements but i think in
different countries different approaches
will be needed
you know in the us things like our
children's trust
legal battles are going to be important
in the uk it might be more the citizen
assembly approach
and i think it was interesting to see
the way you kind of
made an index of how democracies
actually do think longer term but i
think we we do have the cyclical problem
of democracies
where you know if we have a if we have
an election that's you know cycle that's
four years or eight years
but we have um policies that need to
help
people over generations do you have any
thoughts on how to kind of
you know unwind some of that cyclical
nature in democracies and help
help a politician think many decades
ahead
it's really difficult of course because
politicians have
their own life cycles their ministerial
careers and
you know i'm not saying that we ought to
be getting rid of elections and having
elections every 12 years or every 22
years
i just think that we need to layer on
top of it
are the kinds of long-term thinking and
forecasting
institutions and of course long-term
institutions do exist in many political
forms that's what public services are
judiciaries are for example they can
have their own problems by locking in
certain kinds of political views for uh
years and sometimes decades as
we're seeing in the us at the moment but
i do believe that we need to have
multiple
voices as it were certainly democracies
cannot rest easy even though
21 of the top 25 scores and that
intergenerational solidarity index of
democracies
it doesn't mean they can just lay back
every single
democracy in the world could be
deepening its democracy could be
lengthening their their views you know
in finland there's a parliamentary
committee for the future which has been
around since 1993.
you know wales has its future
generations commissioner we so we need
to
bring those into our existing processes
and of course there will always be
struggles between
short-term uh necessities dealing with
immediate crises and the need to deal
with
very long-term issues but of course
sometimes those overlap so if you look
at
wales the future generations
commissioner there her name sophie howe
she tries to focus on issues which
benefit both current and future
generations things like
you know renewable energy you know
changing the transport system
air pollution all that kind of stuff
helps today it helps the citizens of
tomorrow right
and uh i think the one of the
interesting principles i think that
we've
been experimenting with that long now is
this idea of of kind of trusting the
future
uh more than i think we often do this
and and that we can we we
do need to put blind trust into future
generations that they
they fundamentally know more about their
presence than we can possibly predict
about our future
um and this idea of increasing
optionality and i think you kind of
of making sure that they have as many
choices as possible
and you kind of touched on that a little
bit but i wonder if you
talk a little bit about kind of how much
we trust the future or not and how much
we should
that's a really fascinating question i
guess the starting point for my thinking
about
this is to go back to those citizen
assemblies one of the reasons i like
them is because they come up with a
multiplicity
of different futures because you've got
people from very different social
backgrounds you're not getting
the future that just a corporate ceo
wants but it might be
a future that somebody who's living on
the social margins or has experienced
deep racism
in their life wants and it's really
important that we
envisage and envision a multiplicity of
futures i think one of the really
uh important things about black lives
matter for example
is the way that it has spoken in in many
respects the language of
intergenerational justice and injustice
so there's a very important book
written by leila f called me and white
supremacy
and on the first page of that book she
talks about being a good ancestor why
because
as i understand it you know her view is
that well the the racism and the
the colonial inheritances and the
slavery inheritances are being passed
down from generation to generation
over the long term embedded
in cultural political economic
institutions you know throughout society
so
i think that we need to in a way trust
the citizens of the present
to envisage multiple futures there isn't
just one future out there as the
futurist
uh futurists like to tell us i think
that's absolutely true but on the other
side of that
i think it's really important to point
out that we are not simply living in a
world
of mass uncertainty i'm often at
meetings with government for example
where there are a lot of foresight
experts and the language is all about oh
it's also uncertain everything's so
uncertain we're in these
times of turbulence and that's true to a
certain extent but
we also know a lot about the future we
know that we have pushed over planetary
boundaries as we saw in that doughnut
picture there we know about the great
acceleration
we don't know exactly how much sea
levels are going to rise and how fast or
exactly how much temperature is going to
go up by 2100 but
we have a pretty good idea and with that
kind of certainty we can kind of
work for what we knew no future
generations are going to need
ultimately air to breathe food to eat
water to drink
that gives us a pretty clear telos yeah
there's definitely some individual
inevitabilities of of these things um so
i'm going to ask a few questions from
our audience
that tuned in today and then we'll we'll
also be bringing in kevin kelly and
stuart brandt uh pretty soon
but uh ayori selassie uh asks
um how can technology be more of an
enabler of
the good ancestor instead of the
short-term soothing mechanism
yeah i think they're really important
questions about how
technology can be transformed and
used to expand our time horizons create
a long-now civilization because
of course we do tend to think of
technology particularly our phones as
something which is
drawing us into the here and the now we
are clicking we are swiping we are
we're scrolling i think there's some
really interesting examples in the world
of um
uh virtual and augmented reality uh
experiences you know i'm i once founded
a museum that's still around called the
empathy
museum and what one of the exhibits we
have is called a mile in my shoes it's a
gigantic shoe box
which travels around the world and you
can actually go inside it it's the
world's first empathy shoe shop you go
in
and you're fitted with a pair of shoes
belonging to a stranger they could
belong to
a guy who's been in prison for 14 years
or a syrian refugee or a brazilian sex
worker
and you can literally walk a mile in
their shoes while listening to an audio
narrative of them talking about their
own life
in their own words the problem though is
how do you do that
for future generations right when you
cannot put on their shoes or
um have a conversation with them or look
them in the eye and that's where i think
virtual reality is going to be important
um you know in stanford there's the
virtual human interactions lab where you
can go and
experience what it's like to witness
coral bleaching
over the next 100 years and that's
an extraordinary thing to do and it in a
way writes the future
onto our skins by giving us a whole
sensory experience but of course
that kind of technology isn't well
developed yet or at least it's not
um spread on a scale which um is really
has the power yet to shift society on a
large scale but i'd love to see
kind of new kinds of hacking inventions
when it comes to technology i'd like to
see instead of a buy now button a buy
later button
so when you go to buy something online
you get a drop down menu yeah you can
buy now but maybe you can buy in a week
or buy in a month or buy in a year or
borrow from a friend
and if you press buy buy in a month well
you get an email in a month's time
saying
well do you really want that third yoga
mat if you do okay go ahead
so i think there's a lot more work that
can be done around
technology and challenging myopia nice
and we'll bring in a stewart brand
after this i know uh today is is kind of
the first day
you guys have actually met uh in at
least in
uh real time um and
we have a question from uh deepesh
chaudhary
and he asks can you offer some examples
of nudges one could use to inject
long-termism into more everyday life
yeah the question of nudges is really
important you know to be honest
i am not a great believer uh in
sort of nudge approaches that kind of
behavioral psychology stuff i believe
it's
really fundamental to um inculcate new
values in society it's about
paradigm change at the deep level that's
the work of donnella meadows systems
thinkers
thomas kuhn and others but nudge
thinking
is important it does have a role so let
me give an example to answer the
question
so here's something absolutely
fascinating about the way people
write their wills in the united kingdom
most people in the uk on average six
percent of people
will leave a charitable bequest in their
will in other words a gift for future
generations for people or planet
six percent but if they are asked while
they're writing their will
a simple question which is this would
you like to leave a charitable
request in your will it goes up from six
percent to 12
and then if they happen to be asked this
question
this is more or less the wording if
someone says to them a lot of people
like
leaving a gift to charity in their wills
is there
an issue that you are really passionate
about well suddenly it jumps to 17
in other words these are behavioral
nudges ways of switching on you know
that
acorn brain which i was mentioning
earlier i'll take away the marshmallow
you know so there there is there is a
potential for no genomics
uh in this realm certainly great well
we'll bring in uh stewart
greetings hi there stuart
um well first of all congratulations on
the book and on this talk i
love what you're doing and the
directions it's going
and in terms of the directions it's
going you finished the book
some while ago the book is now
out in england coming out the u.s and
you're seeing response to you're seeing
response to these talks
and so i imagine you're starting to see
things that um
are taking your ideas and thought
further
and that you might put some of them in
an epilogue to the paperback edition
that comes out in a year or so or
something like that
what have you been learning since you
finished the book
yeah that's really fascinating actually
because when a book comes out as you
know from your own books it's really
hard to
know exactly how people are going to
respond so the first thing that really
struck me was
how many governments wanted to think
about
long-term thinking and that they weren't
only just interested in
scenario planning trying to make kind of
predictions for
the various futures that might be out
there they're concerned about
how do we get people to actually care
about
the future to care about those future
generations to really
buy into it so i was at a really
fascinating meeting of british members
of parliament
recently where i was giving them a
briefing on the book and we were
in a way testing out different kinds of
language that would work with
uh politicians and kind of metaphors and
things like that
and what it turned out was certainly
what i saw what the evidence suggested
was that
talking about the probability of bad
things happening asteroids hitting us
or or statistics about climate change
didn't really connect with them
what really connected was talking about
their children and grandchildren
going very personal so i've been really
struck by
um that that interest in government and
in fact just next week i'm going to
a meeting again in the uk about
synthetic biology and
what should be the government's
long-term planning around this and i
think it's just really interesting that
they're even inviting me along and i
think there's a there's something in the
air in the eu
canada other countries so that's really
struck me and then the other thing i
think is
is um business you know the way
that social enterprises even massive
corporations
are responding to this book and i think
they're not just responding to my book
in particular but just that
importance of trying to think long term
so even you know
i've been approached by some of the
world's biggest mining companies
who to me certainly don't seem to have a
very long term
vision but even they are trying to think
how do we become regenerative how do we
lower our carbon emissions how do we
become circular so
there is really something in the air and
i think this is what the long now
foundation has been
kind of generating over the last you
know 20 years
of work at least actually changing the
public conversation but what are you
what have you been noticing about
uh the the the way that long-term
thinking's being talked about in recent
months and years
uh just the fact that you know your book
is out there and there are other things
that you refer to
are out there as becoming a subject
in my own case i'm pursuing the concept
of maintenance
as an important thing to take on and
i'll be
quoting your book a lot in the chapter
on civilization that'll be in there
but one follow-up question i'm curious
when you're talking with the government
about synthetic biology and biotech in
general and
which then extends into tech in general
i can't completely predict how
you're going to come out on that you
might be
what i regard as overly cautious don't
try things unless you know exactly
what's happening
or you might look there's so much good
that can be done by these technologies
let's
check out what they can do for us where
do you come out on that
i wish i knew um i really feel
uh pulled in different directions a lot
of these things i am by nature
a technological skeptic um
you know probably unlike maybe many
people in this audience
and you know that's just where i'm
coming from so i've tried to make a huge
effort to engage with
technology thinkers and writers and
companies and i've
visited nuclear fusion projects and all
sorts of stuff like that
and i think synthetic biology you know
is is one of those really really
interesting ones because on the one hand
i'm moving towards the idea that we are
definitely going to need
synthetic foods to feed 10 billion
people by
2050. i can hardly see that there's
any way that we can uh avoid
that um you know even if we were all
switching you know to
vegetarian diets um or even vegan diets
um so there's that angle but on the
other hand i can see that the
corporate world is trying to buy out a
lot of you know synthetic biology and
you know if we're talking about
using it to meet basic human needs
there's a really important
conversation to have with government
about how to regulate
uh those industries so you know i'm
still sort of in a way
finding my uh way uh
you know on that and i don't pretend to
be an expert in any of these kinds of
areas but i like the fact that i'm
changing my views
on a lot of these things i recently came
across
a really fantastic talk by the danish
architect
bjarke ingles actually a ted talk
where he was talking about mars
colonization and pointing out that the
technology required to
live on mars like to have a non-fossil
fuel based energy system or to live with
very little water is exactly what we
need to learn to do on earth so there's
a kind of
a confluence there and that was sort of
been challenging my thinking too
yeah and we saw that with the photograph
of the earth from space
the space program was fought by every
environmentalist i know except
jacques cousteau um so you know
sometimes you see the unexpected the
uh unexpected uh consequences
are beneficial and you can push for that
well and i love john maynard keynes who
said when the facts change i changed my
mind what do you do sir
right thank you so much stuart
it's great to have you uh yeah i think
that's it's an interesting
case of you know you you point out these
ideas of these transcendent goals and in
some cases those transcendent goals can
inspire people to
you know hyper develop a technology you
know if we can decarbonize mars we could
really decarbonize our planet
uh you know it's all co2 atmosphere
basically there so if
if we can figure out how to sync all of
that i think we'd be we'd be
doing very well to terraform our own
planet uh very easily so
um so i think that that's that's well
worth doing and we'll bring in
um we'll bring in kevin kelly after this
question from shel kappen
um he asks uh how do we create
institutions that
incentivize people to cooperate with
investing
in long-term thinking versus defecting
to their own short-term benefit
and it's kind of i guess the
institutional question of where where do
we get this
where do we get these types of
institutions i think that's a really
difficult
uh and interesting question um i think
it depends what realm
that you are envisaging so let's have a
look at the political realm firstly
go back to that example of japan
now when people put on their uh their
robes and imagine themselves in 2016
something really interesting happens
they are become willing to
sacrifice um for future generations so
there's a famous case in japan as part
of this movement where
the citizens of a town were asked if
they were willing to pay
higher water rates higher water taxes
in order to repair the decrepit water
infrastructure
in order to help their children or
grandchildren 50 years
70 years from now and in fact using this
future design method
literally by imagining themselves in the
year 2060
they were willing to accept a six
percent rise in their water taxes
it's a very small example but i think
it's really significant because it
it shows that in a way i think those
people didn't see it as a sacrifice they
saw it as an intergenerational gift
right but they were only able to see it
that way when they had gone on this
imaginative
time travel become a resident of the
future temporarily by
by by dressing themselves up in effect
so i think that's
one behavioral way that we can
incentivize
people by taking them on imaginative
journeys using the extraordinary
capacity of the human mind to
pirouette across time scales you know
to to move between thinking on a scale
of seconds and minutes and hours to
decades centuries and even millennia and
then i think in the economic world
it's uh there are complexities there as
well we've seen you know really
interesting shifts of behavioral uh
structures so
the company unilever for example one the
world's biggest you know
food stuff consumer companies well when
paul pullman became
uh ceo about 10 or 11 years ago he
abolished quarterly reporting on the day
that he took over
uh he he famously said that you know
that he thought that they couldn't even
fire him on the first day that's why he
did it
and he fought a battle right he fought a
battle to make that company more
sustainable
very strict long-term uh goals on
sustainability and sourcing around their
suppliers
but he was in a struggle why because the
company was owned by shareholders right
he was subject to
hostile takeover bids from kraft heinz
uh and others
so even though you may have your purpose
may embody long-term thinking if your
ownership and finance
is still based on short-term incentive
structures you are always going
to struggle you know you're always going
to struggle and that's why
i'm you know particularly impressed by
companies which are trying to shift away
from those models so in britain
the one of the biggest renewable energy
suppliers good
energy is 60 owned by its customers
and that in a way ties it to longer term
sustainable principles or
the dutch bank triodos which is
spreading rapidly around the world
well their shares are all held in a
trust a kind of foundation
and they have their own platform for
trading their shares and it protects the
principles of
long-termism and sustainability around
their investments so
there's all sorts of structures we could
be using i think we're going to need to
use
and invent a whole load of different
kinds for different realms and different
countries
nice and we'll uh we'll bring in kevin
kelly
welcome kevin hey roman hey i
thought i agree with what alexander says
which is i think this is probably the
most
long nowish talk that we've ever had
and it's the talk that i will point
people to when
i have to explain what long now thinking
is about
so i think one of the things that your
book and talk
tries to do that's one of the most
difficult things to do
is to describe a future that we want to
aim for to have this
one thriving planet in in the future but
i have to say that
when you take away this kind of
perpetual growth model
it's on first appearance a future that
seems stagnant that seems to have no
future in itself
it's like well we arrive there and then
is it utopia is it the same
what changes what happens over time
what is growing and of course growing
in english is where they have two
meanings when we can grow in size
and get fat or we can grow up
get better and so um there's
developmental growth which is the kind
of growth that we've been having and
then there's
evolutionary growth so we kind of
want a world that keeps getting better
that grows in some dimension
perpetually so can you
is is there kind of a metric or quantity
or
measurement or evidence that you would
say in 100 years
this shows we've been good we've become
good ancestors what would that
how could we prove or what evidence
would we have
that in a hundred years during a
thousand years we were good ancestors
and then
in a thousand years after that we were
even better ancestors so
i guess i'm interested in not just good
ancestors but better ancestors how do we
keep getting better and
what is that dimension so
sort of in response to the first part i
think when i'm talking about
one planet thriving this is not a
stagnant
state this is not a state of stability
think of the amazon rainforest okay
which has reached a kind of well before
it started being chopped down a kind of
stability but it is not stagnant
right it's not growing growing growing
outwards but it's in perpetual
motion yeah in many ways circular is it
going anywhere is there a direction
is there a teals to the rainforest
well i'm i don't think there is a kind
of tea loss except that it's
a regenerative system it's moving around
a lot and in the same way as if you
think about donut economics model when
you're in that
light green space above the social
foundation and within
the uh ecological ceiling you know there
came can well be movement going on
your economy might be growing uh you
know at some point
um but then it might not be growing in
numerical terms in others so for example
you might put
huge investment into uh solar energy
for example now that is going to
increase your gdp just
you know but mathematically it's going
to do that but then over the long term
you're not you're not going to be
spending money
on all of that kind of infrastructure
yet
your economy may be developing in all
sorts of interesting and important
ways so i think that going anywhere is
there anything that's
getting better over time well all sorts
of things can be getting over time
culturally for example you know here i
am holding up kim stanley robinson's
book the ministry for the future
you know there's all sorts of realms
where we will be excelling ourselves but
i think what we need to stop doing is
thinking that
the way to advance that the meaning of
progress
has to be reduced to uh material
progress
you know and and that's why you know one
could use language of well-being of
cultural development all sorts of
different ways to
you know you know i think that in a way
that's what people like
bertrand russell love that idea that
we'd be working four hours a day and
have the rest of the day free to
you know do all sorts of things be
artists scientists whatever we want so i
certainly don't see this
kind of telos as a uh as a stagnant
state but i definitely do think
it's one about um in terms of herman
daly's sort of idea of
staying within kind of boundaries and we
we stay in boundaries
all the time we're used to one boundary
in the last couple of hundred years that
we don't own slaves
right and and we put certain
restrictions on ourselves and when we
operate within those
so in this difficult task of trying to
imagine this future i think it would be
useful to have
some kind of of measurements or
evidences that would prove that we had
succeeded
um so you mentioned kim stanley robinson
or i know
maybe there would be more science
fiction stories or better science
fiction stories
what what is that thing that would be
evidence that we could use
to to prove that this is working so so
do
you do you have things that you could
say well there's
um less of this or there's more of this
and that in
a thousand years after that there'd be
even more or is this something that
alexander's idea that we don't even
actually know and we shouldn't even try
and make those criteria and we should
let the future generations decide this
is this kind of
trusting in the future versus
dumping the problems on them maybe we
should equip
the future generations to solve the
problems rather than
we're going to solve the problems or
tell you what problems to solve we're
just going to
try to equip you to solve our problems
in the future i i you know so
do you have a picture of what that would
look like in 100 years if
we became good ancestors well i
certainly think that there are
sensible metrics that we can adopt i
mean the
you know global footprint network you
know has a measure of
how many planet earths that are we using
each year in terms of our
resource you know use and carbon
footprints at the moment it's about 1.6
it's gone down slightly because of
covert 19. and and so there's this thing
as you know called earth overshoot day
the day beyond which we're using more
resources than the planet can naturally
regenerate and can naturally absorb and
it's probably something like about
august to something this this year and
we need to shift it back to december
31st now that's a
very obvious metric but within that
well the sky's the limit once you've
learned to do that that's how i kind of
think about the mars exploration idea
you know
once we've learned to live within one
planet well take as many trips to mars
as you like
you know fantastic you know there's
incredible
freedoms once we are in that realm so
i mean i do think though that that
intergenerational solidarity index i
mentioned is
is useful i think at least on the
governmental level to have them
something to aim at something you can
hold them to account on
year on year on long-term policy
performance otherwise you know it's
quite hard to
um actually sort of yeah hold them to
account ultimately
thank you thank you kevin um so we're
going to be wrapping up the questions
here uh in just a moment but um
i did want to ask um
one of the questions from from online
from rafael ciceros
um at what point during someone's life
should long-term thinking begin
to be taught like how do should this be
should this be taught to young people in
schools or
are young are how young a mind can
really think uh
long-term and this is something that we
work on that long now but
i'd love to get your take on that yeah
so i've done a lot of research on
empathy
and the capacity to put ourselves in
someone else's shoes and what's really
interesting about empathy is that you
can teach it
like riding a bike or driving a car
so there's a project in canada called
roots of empathy
where they bring a baby into the
classroom the kids sit around the baby
and they start talking about the baby
why is the baby crying or laughing why
is she suddenly looking over at their
mother or father
they're trying to step into the baby's
shoes they use that then as a jumping
off point for talking about well what's
it like to be a
bullet kid bullied in the playground or
a family living on the streets of
calcutta
so kids learn this capacity to step
into the shoes of others in fact even by
the age of three or four
and in that roots of empathy project
they also have an element where they
try and get the kids to imagine what's
this baby's life going to be like in
10 years 20 years what responsibilities
might we have towards them
so i absolutely believe that this kind
of long-term thinking
should be mainstreamed in education
i mean certainly in elementary school
and and afterwards as well because
kids get this idea of making imaginative
journeys they can do this right
that is the power of the human mind i
mean it's an extraordinary
um you know machine extraordinary tool
i mean of course when human beings reach
mid-life that's when they tend to start
thinking about their legacies for when
they're gone how am i going to keep the
fire of my own
life still burning and in psychology
there's this whole field called
generativity
this idea of generativity that idea that
we need to
find we will seek we we tend to seek
ways to
keep ourselves alive when we go when
we're gone we tend to think about it in
terms of
leaving a legacy for our children but i
believe we need to do something bigger
than that but if we can start early um
not just thinking uh teaching futures
thinking but also
about the the moral aspects of long-term
thinking we will be doing a service to
current and future generations
yeah indeed i think i'm always struck by
how easily um
children empathize with you know
dinosaurs for instance
60 something 65 million years before
they were born they're fascinated by
dinosaurs or space aliens
uh and space in itself is kind of a
long-term
uh endeavor and both of those things do
seem to capture imaginations of children
so i think that's a it's a great space
to play in
uh and before we close i wanted to ask
you know i know that you're kind of
starting in a way your book tour
and now that you're you're just now
launching this book uh
whatever book tours are these days but
uh what
do you have new projects that you're
working on uh new areas of research that
you're thinking about
you know normally i have my next book
ready to go when i finish one but
this is proving different partly in
relation to what
stewart was asking about the kind of
public response
to this book and you know other people
who are also writing
you know books about long-term thinking
in deep time there is something in the
air and so i've decided to dedicate at
least the next five years
to trying to roll out the ideas in
different ways whether it's working with
government
whether it's trying to invent new art
projects like that empathy museum step
into someone else's shoes
i love to crack that one of how to step
into the shoes of future generations how
to
invent that app which is the buy buy
later button instead of the buy now
button so
i'm looking to work with all sorts of
organizations to
try and stretch these ideas out into the
future and then i'll also be doing it in
my own family too during the last uk
general election
my partner and i decided to give our
votes to our
11 year old twins and we sat around the
kitchen table debated the party
manifestos and they told us where to put
that x on the ballot sheet
and i hope to be doing that a lot as
well so having conversations at home
about long-termism too nice well if uh
long now foundation can work with you on
any of your endeavors over the next five
years
uh uh please consider us your close ally
as always and we look forward to
seeing and hearing more from you in the
future thank you very much
thank you for the conversation really
enjoyed it
[Music]
you